[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au
alors nous nous voici enfin de retour
mes chers petits amis ce coup je me suis
ennuyeux sans vous patron je descend
vite jouée chez pipo la propre peuple in
north mais n'oublie pas qu'il doive se
coucher de bonne heure
on prolonge était
alors sur la peur je suis bien content
d'eux
c'est la fille
pour
maya personnes à saint lô
[Musique]
un oiseau à ibou
6 juillet
prochain du matin au soir les enfants
john lennon sera guère regard on a une
visite juliette un marcheur comment vas
tu mais tu n'es pas venu seul
dieu là où j'ai pas tué voix
[Musique]
grinçante brice
wahnich joué
qu attendait pas tu as bien fait venir
je tue des selon deux formidables salut
salut d'un échafaud locaux parce que tu
cherchais donne on va t'aider tiens
tiens moi ça le nous
boudons mary jo bien sûr cornichons bon
mais j'ai encore des affaires sous le
panier on va les chercher chercher en il
faire attention c'est fragile
très bien là
ce que le pic on se rencontre une minute
je reviens
dada
ça y est dis à papa et un moment que
c'est d'accord je peux rester
[Musique]
tu reviendras me chercher
tout d'abord j'aimerais bien savoir
pourquoi pourquoi
pour juillet ta bouche pas jma cloud
attention à mais pas tous
tu peux lâcher il tient tout seul c'est
un beau château mais oui mais c'est
aussi la bo pour juliette mais bien mon
petit corps du show tu as fait une
longue route pour venir ici tu es
sûrement fatigué
non vous jouerez demain toute la journée
à lui ou les
tu viendra jouer avec nous bien sûr
en une annonce bonne n'est qu'un méchant
ou tortue comme t'inquiète pas nous nous
je prépare mon quoi près de la forêt
avec juliette
[Musique]
bleu nuit nous nous
fais de beaux rêves
[Musique]
où
oh
je l'état ne va pas dehors cette nuit
c'est un pays que tu ne connais pas tu
pourrais te perdre
dans bien juliette 1
[Musique]
allons-nous nours dépêche-toi voilà à
trop bonne nuit des enfants à demain
fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
en